[Musik]
verhandlungsmarathon in brüssel beim
eu-gipfel erzielen die regierungschefs
offenbar einen ersten durchbruch
konsequenzen der krawallnacht nach den
randalen in frankfurt am main setzt die
stadt auf mehr polizeipräsenz und
schwert nachts den opernplatz aufbruch
ins all mit der mission hoffnung
schicken die vereinigten arabischen
emirate erstmals eine sonde zum mars
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster büttenabend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten mit sport und
norbert lehmann im studio einen schönen
guten abend so von mir und noch einmal
ist der eu-gipfel in brüssel in die
verlängerung gegangen
doch jetzt scheint man sich einig zu
sein wie die korona bedingte
wirtschaftskrise in der europäischen
union bekämpft werden soll
die sehr unterschiedlichen interessen
von nord- süd- und einigen ost ländern
hatten die suche nach einem kompromiss
lange verzögert noch ist nichts
offiziell aber so könnte die lösung wohl
aussehen der eu aufbau von ursprünglich
ein volumen von 750 milliarden euro vor
250 milliarden sollten als kredite
vergeben werden und 500 milliarden als
zuschüsse die nicht zurückgezahlt werden
müssen
vor allem um diese summe wurde heftig
gerungen
die zuschüsse sollen nun wohl auf 390
milliarden euro gesenkt werden
rückwardt berichtet es geht mühsam voran
in kleinen schritten auch am vierten
gipfeltag sind noch weitere streitpunkte
zu lösen
die beitrags- rückzahlungen an einzelne
mitgliedstaaten zum beispiel auch hier
bleibt der niederländische
regierungschef räte hart sieht er beim
haushalt wollen wir für uns höhere
rabatte und beim hilfsfonds fordern wir
verbindliche reformzusagen der
empfängerstaaten worden bundeskanzlerin
merkel versucht unterdessen den ersten
gipfel unter ihrer ratspräsidentschaft
vor einem scheitern zu bewahren
wir haben gestern nach nach langer
verhandlung einen rahmen für eine
mögliche einigung gearbeitet
das ist ein fortschritt und gibt
hoffnung dass es heute vielleicht seiner
einigung kommt oder jedenfalls eine
einigung möglich ist
das gefeilsche so kritisieren italiener
und spanier verdrängen zunehmend das
eigentliche ziel des gipfels eine
gemeinsame anstrengung zur
stabilisierung der wirtschaft in arisch
brust da wir brauchen eine antwort auf
die krise unsere bürger die arbeitnehmer
die unternehmen brauchen zuversicht dass
wir die folgen der pandemie meistern
können
mehr die nächste hürde die am abend auf
die gipfelrunde wartet ist die
diskussion über den zustand des
rechtsstaats in ländern wie ungarn oder
polen
die regierungschefs orban und moravetz
gewinnen eine kopplung von eu-zahlungen
an die einhaltung rechtsstaatlicher
standards strikt ab andere fordern genau
das war noch zu einem europa wo
rechtsstaat und grundrechte verhandelbar
sind sagen wir nein
jk nun ist war vor einer stunde wollten
die 27 in großer runde weiter verhandeln
doch die sitzung wurde erneut verschoben
ja frage nach brüssel wo stefan leifert
den neuesten stand hat stefan ist denn
damit jetzt alles in trockenen tüchern
oder lässt orban doch noch alles platzen
nach wie vor ist alles völlig offen der
gipfel geht jetzt in eine weitere lange
verhandlungsnacht mit einem ergebnis
heute abend kann man so gut wie nicht
mehr rechnen das ist ausgeschlossen wenn
dieser gipfel bis 23 uhr 20 tag dann
hätte er sogar einen europäischen rekord
erreicht und wäre er der längste der
europäischen geschichte und danach sieht
es im moment aus im moment überwiegt
erst einmal die erleichterung darüber
dass es jetzt ein kompromiss einen
richtigen durchbruch gibt bei dem thema
was den gipfel drei tage lang gelähmt
hat nämlich die frage wie hoch die
zuschüsse sind in corona fonds für die
krisengebeutelten länder offenbar haben
sich jetzt alle seiten mit dieser zahl
von 390 milliarden angefreundet
was jetzt noch bleibt ist eine ziemlich
große hürde die frage der
rechtsstaatlichkeit das ist nicht
einfach zu lösen weil alle protagonisten
hier ziemlich hoch auf die bäume
geklettert sind da ist auf der einen
seite viktor orban der gesagt hat er
werde diesen gipfel nicht verlassen mit
einer einigung wenn diese einigung
beinhaltet dass es so einen rechtsstaats
mechanismus gibt mark rutte der
niederländische premier seinerseits hat
gesagt er werde eine einigung nur
zustimmen wenn die vergabe von eu
mitteln künftig an die
rechtsstaatlichkeit gekoppelt ist also
das kann eine ziemlich lange nacht
werden ein kompromiss ist vor allem
deswegen so schwer weil es kein
dazwischen gibt man könnte das thema
höchstens vertragen oder ein land
formelkompromiss finden die sorge ist
jedenfalls groß dass das thema der
rechtsstaatlichkeit geopfert wird um
jetzt hier am fünften tag oder in der
nächsten nacht endlich zu einer einigung
zu kommen
danke für ihre erklärung stefan leifert
frankfurt am main zieht konsequenzen aus
der krawallnacht vom wochenende auf dem
opernplatz hatten sich hunderte zum
feiern getroffen später die eskalation
randalierer griffen polizisten an unter
dem jubel der umstehenden
am kommenden wochenende wird der platz
ab mitternacht gesperrt in der ganzen
stadt werden den kontrollen verstärkt
dominik löschmeister berichtet bilder
wie diese vom frankfurter opernplatz
wollen die verantwortlichen von stadt
und polizei nicht mehr sehen hunderte
junge leute die polizisten angreifen die
stadt frankfurt reagiert einmal wird der
opernplatz auf ein uhr nachts gesperrt
vorher um 0 uhr gibt es ein
betretungsverbot darüber hinaus haben
wir für die störer für die kriminellen
störer ein aufenthaltsverbot auf den weg
gebracht die 39 tatverdächtigen haben
nach polizeiangaben überwiegend an den
migrationshintergrund sind meist
polizeibekannt frankfurt oder stuttgart
da die klubs wegen corona geschlossen
sind zieht es viele junge menschen ins
freie
aufgestaute stimmung gegen die
ordnungshüter für die gewerkschaft der
polizei hat sich auch was verändert
durch die geschehnisse in den usa möchte
aber gleich sagen dass die deutsche
polizei per se nicht vergleichbar ist
mit der amerikanischen von daher tut das
sehr weh und zum zweiten natürlich die
vorwürfe die uns speziell bei der
hessischen polizei angetragen werden die
ich nicht teile ausdrücklich nicht teile
es gebe rechtsradikalen netzwerke bei
der polizei und alles zusammen hat sich
entladen in frankfurt
all cops are bastards alle polizisten
sind bastarde liefen erst jugendliche in
den usa jetzt auch in frankfurt für
experten eine gefährliche entwicklung wo
solche parolen gerufen werden folgen
natürlich mit einer gewissen logik dann
auch die pflastersteine und
möglicherweise brechstangen die krawalle
am opernplatz in frankfurt sollen sich
nicht wiederholen
am wochenende will die polizei ein
nächtliches betretungsverbot durchsetzen
der fall war card der wahrscheinlich
größte bilanzskandal der deutschen
finanzgeschichte kommt nicht aus den
schlagzeilen
eine 1,9 milliarden euro luftbuchung
tauchte bei dem zahlungsdienstleister
aus bayern auf die folgen dax
rausschmiss insolvenz strafanzeige und
ein manager auf der flucht der
ex-vorstand die an marschalek ist
offenbar in russland untergetaucht
womöglich mit hilfe des
militärgeheimdienstes andreas künast auf
spurensuche
es sind vor allem zwei große rätsel die
die pleite von wirecard auf gibt wo sind
die 1,9 milliarden euro
und wo ist er nach jandt marschalek
suchen staatsanwälte gläubiger und die
bundesregierung und einige geheimdienste
offenbar auch im wirecard vorstand war
marschalek die nummer zwei als bei
nummer eins konzernchef braun die
handschellen klickten hat marschalek
nicht nur die flucht ergriffen sondern
mit hohem aufwand falsche spuren gelegt
auf die philippinen und nach china
aber inzwischen lässt außenminister maß
berichte prüfen wonach sich marschalek
in moskau befindet wir sind zur zeit
dabei uns mit diesem thema
auseinandersetzt zu setzen und die für
uns wichtigen informationen zu sammeln
aber es ist zurzeit zu früh darüber
abschließend eine beurteilung abzugeben
die schlüsselfigur der wirecard pleite
sehen seine mitarbeiter am 18
juni zum letzten mal dann startet der
privatjet
vermutlich von klagenfurt vermutlich
über tallinn nach minsk in weißrussland
von dort soll ein russischer
geheimdienst marschalek nach moskau
gebracht haben mit kontakten zu
russlands militär nachrichtendienst
hatte marschalek häufig geprahlt die
russische wendung die vielen fragen
werden für deutschlands diplomatie zu
einer ungeahnten herausforderung der
kreml teilt bereits mit zum
aufenthaltsort von marschall ick sei
nichts bekannt
1,9 milliarden euro dies offenbar nie
gab
weitere informationen und hintergründe
zum bilanzskandal bei wirecard finden
sie in unserer zdf heute app in
deutschland ist die zahl der
neuinfektionen mit dem corona virus
leicht gestiegen bleibt aber weiter auf
niedrigem niveau
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 400 menschen
infiziert gestern und vorgestern waren
es 390 seinen schrecken wird das corona
virus erst dann verlieren wenn ein
sicherer impfstoff zur verfügung steht
viele arbeiten daran
150 substanzen gelten als aussichtsreich
das mainzer unternehmen bei montech und
sein us-partner pfizer berichten heute
über fortschritte mit einem impfstoff
der gentechnisch hergestellt wird wie so
etwas funktioniert erklärt delia thomas
wird das corona virus mit einem gen
basierten impfstoff bekämpft erhält der
körper die erbgutinformationen eine art
bauplan des erregers
damit können die menschlichen zellen die
proteine des virus selbst produzieren
auf diese proteine reagiert dann das
immunsystem und bildet zum schutz
antikörper allerdings gibt es gehen
basierte impfstoffe nur in der forschung
deshalb fehlt es noch an erfahrung wie
lange ein solcher impfschutz anhält
für gehen basierte impfstoffe spricht
dass sie in kurzer zeit in großen mengen
hergestellt werden können
auch die nebenwirkungen der impfung
fallen geringer aus
unter anderem weil bei gen basierten
impfstoffen der menschliche körper nur
teile des erregers produziert piontek
und weise haben ihren impfstoff
inzwischen
menschen getestet um herauszufinden ob
die versuchspersonen danach eine
immunreaktion zeigen also antikörper
gebildet haben und ob es nebenwirkungen
gibt julia schröter berichtet dies ist
der erste proband mit diesem stich
beginnt die bayern- tech studie
insgesamt 60 menschen wurde der
impfstoff injiziert das ergebnis im
labor schon bei niedrigen dosen bildeten
die probanden antikörper mehr sogar als
im blut von menschen gefunden wurden die
eine kurve 19 infektion überstanden
haben
außerdem entwickelten die probanden
sogenannte t zellen die für das im
gedächtnis wichtig sind
wir sind überzeugt dass beide
mechanismen eine wichtige rolle für die
wirksame bekämpfung von
krankheitserregern wie saas kauf zwei
spielen könnten
die nebenwirkungen im test hielten sich
in grenzen berichtet biontech forscher
sprechen von ermutigenden ergebnissen
wir haben ja zwei verschiedene im unama
das sind die antikörper und die t zellen
und die firma konnte zeigen dass
eigentlich beide arme gleichermaßen
angesprochen werden
wir haben sehr hohe antikörpertiter die
auch neutralisieren sind als das virus
in aktivieren
und wir haben auch tc von denen wir weit
von ihr wissen dass sie länger aktiv
bleiben
der impfstoff soll in der finalen phase
3 nun in kürze an bis zu 30.000
probanden getestet werden
in europa den usa und argentinien orte
wo das virus gerade grassiert dann muss
sich erweisen ob der impfstoff auch in
der praxis tatsächlich schützt und denn
nicht nur im labor funktioniert
piontek jedenfalls ist zuversichtlich
und hofft noch in diesem jahr eine
zulassung zu bekommen
bei der erprobung noch einen schritt
weiter ist der britische pharmakonzern
astrazeneca und die universität oxford
sie haben tests bei mehr als 1000
freiwilligen durchgeführt und heute
ebenfalls gute ergebnisse gemeldet
ob die dabei nachgewiesenen antikörper
allerdings ausreichen um vor einer
infektion zu schützen ist bei allen
getesteten impfstoffe noch völlig offen
ganz anderes thema die diskussion um
rechtsextremisten in der bundeswehr hat
dem jahrestag des gescheiterten hitler
als heute besondere aktualität verliehen
am 20 juli 1944 hatte die
widerstandsgruppe um claus schenk graf
von stauffenberg versucht hitler mit
einer bombe zu töten
david gebhard berichtet wer sollen ihre
vorbilder seien
in einer zeit in der von
rechtsextremistischen umtrieben in
teilen der bundeswehr die rede ist sieht
sich die ministerin heute veranlasst
beim gelöbnis junger soldaten eine
trennlinie zu ziehen so wehrmacht
vorbild für die bundeswehr kann aus
dieser zeit nur sein wird zur umkehr in
der lage war wie die widerstandskämpfer
des 20
julis extremisten in der bundeswehr die
sich auf falsche vorbilder stützen die
den nationalsozialismus verharmlosen
oder sogar glorifizieren verraten gerade
das was sie zu ehren vorgeben vor 76
jahren bei einer lagebesprechung
explodiert eine bombe in hitlers
hauptquartier wolfsschanze auf den
führer wurde heute ein
sprengstoffanschlag verübt
doch das ziel hitler zu töten und dessen
verbrecherischen krieg und massenmord zu
beenden scheitert hitler überlebt nur
leicht verletzt staufenberg und andere
widerstandskämpfer werden noch in
derselben nach dem hof des bendlerblocks
in berlin hingerichtet
ich glaube es ist für alle heute und
später lebenden generationen der
deutschen von zentraler befreiender
wirkung
das ist einmal diese menschen im
widerstand gegeben hat die mit der
schuld und der schande ihres volkes
einfach nicht weiterleben wollte
zunächst als verräter noch in der frühen
brd geschmäht längst als helden
gewürdigt der begriff widerstand jedoch
werde zunehmend gekapert wenn sich heute
jemand als widerstand 2020 bezeichnet
oder wenn sich die afg auf den
widerstand begriff beruft dann ist das
nichts anderes als eine okkupation des
widerstands betrifft und die haben eben
nicht begriffen was es bedeutet
widerstand gegen eine diktatur zu
leisten der zwanzigste juli ein tag des
gedenkens ein tag des gewissens ein tag
der seltsam aktuell
76 jahre danach weltraumforschung das
war jahrzehntelang die domäne der
großmächte
doch in diesen exklusiven club drängen
inzwischen auch andere staaten die sich
so etwas leisten können und wollen die
vereinigten arabischen emirate etwa der
golfstaat hat jetzt eine sonde zum mars
geschickt als erste arabische nation uli
gack berichtet countdown arabisch
zweimal wegen schlechtem wetter in japan
verschoben und dann dieser
bilderbuchstart allemal die hoffnung auf
dem weg zu mars angetrieben von einer
japanischen rakete ausgerüstet mit
amerikanischer satellitentechnik
beflügelt von arabische vision die
freude im kontrollzentrum für
emiratische verhältnisse geradezu
grenzenlos die emirate sind nun mitglied
im club wir werden mehr lernen wir
werden uns mehr einbringen und wir
werden unser raum forschungsprogramm
weiterentwicklung diese reise zum mars
ist für die hochfliegenden arabischen
pläne nur ein zwischenschritt
ab februar 2021 soll die sonde den roten
planeten umkreisen und wetterdaten eines
ganzen maries jahres erforschen
der hauptgrund für diese mission ist
dass wir die arabische und emiratische
jugend für naturwissenschaften
begeistern wollen deshalb der name hope
hoffnung für die arabische jugend
vergangenes jahr schon haben die
emiratis einen landsmann zur
internationalen raumstation iss
geschickt jetzt also der griff zu machen
den wollen sie irgendwann sogar
besiedeln eine kühne vision anknüpfend
an die jahrhunderte zuvor als arabien in
der wissenschaft noch führend war ja und
nun zu dir norbert und zum neuen
türkischen fußball meister nach vielen
jahren der langeweile an der
tabellenspitze ist es diesmal nicht
galatasary nicht fern apache oder
besiktas istanbul sondern erstmal bei
che hier
darüber freut sich nicht jeder im
fußballverrückten land denn es ist der
verein des türkischen präsidenten
erdogan der klub hat lange nicht so
viele fans wie die drei großen
istanbuler traditionsvereine
doch die paar die bayer-aktie hier
unterstützen vergaßen gestern abend
jegliche corona etikette und feierten
den ersten titel 1 1 zu 0 am vorletzten
spieltag gegen kayserispor reichte zur
meisterschaft fünf jahre lang waren wir
sehr nah dran
die letzten jahre immer zweiter oder
dritter und sind nur ganz knapp
gescheitert
wir haben viele erfahrene spieler aus
europa viele nationalspieler
für uns war das keine überraschung wir
wussten wir werden meister
das team um trainer okan buruk wird von
unternehmen gesponsert die der
regierungspartei akp nahe stehen denn
ballack hier ist der lieblingsverein des
türkischen präsidenten der gratulierte
gleich nach dem sieg per twitter und
freute sich wohl wie die fans das ist
diesmal endlich geklappt hat dfb
präsident fritz keller will möglichst
schnell wieder zuschauer in die
fußballstadien lassen
mit hilfe von corona massentest und das
erstmals schon am dritten september zum
länderspiel deutschland gegen spanien in
stuttgart bundestrainer joachim löw von
die dfb-elf wären die ersten die wieder
zuschauer begrüßen dürften
angelehnt an das konzept von dfb und dfl
wären es ohnehin nur ein paar tausend
jenaer stadion größe damit das
funktionieren könne seinen tests jedes
einzelne nötig dafür bietet der dfb
seine hilfe an so präsident fritz keller
mit den 25.000 verein habe dieser die
passende infrastruktur und logistik die
müssen wir nutzen
in jedem verein gebe es jemanden
medizinische erfahrung der selbsttest an
leiten könne
schon am morgen nach dem test könnte man
das ergebnis auf dem handy haben bei
negativen testresultate einen
stadionbesuch unbedenklich der
pharmakologe fritz sörgel sieht das
anders schnelltests geben keine
sicherheit auch wenn dieser negativ sein
können zuschauer bis zum spiel corona
positiv werden heißt auch halb volle
stadien können sich zur hot spots für
infektionen entwickeln und wege der
abwechslungsreiche sommer weiter im
norden wie im süden
warm wo gewitter unterwegs sind das
verrät uns gleich ist intelli so viel
von uns für den moment mehr gibt's um
drei viertel 10 mit im heute journal mit
christian sievers wir danken für ihr
interesse und sind morgen wieder hier um
7 einen entspannten abend für sie ein
student und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter die schauer lassen in der zweiten
nachthälfte dann allmählich nach hier im
osten deutschlands gibt es noch welche
und dann wird auch dort weniger
ansonsten aber trocken im westen und im
süden dabei temperaturen im südwesten um
16 grad als tiefster in der
norddeutschen tiefebene morgen bevorzugt
zum nachmittag hin dann kräftige
gewitter von süden her bis zur donau
etwa auch schauer dann an der nordsee
ansonsten aber trockenes wetter nach
osten hin vielleicht mehr wolken aber
insgesamt wenig los temperaturen
erreichen 25 grad im rhein-main-gebiet
und 28 grad im südosten
deutlich wärmer als im norden an den
küsten 18 bis 19 grad
die kommenden tage im süden meist
gewittrig 18 bis 29 grad die höchsten
werte jordan am donnerstag auch im
norden regen damit ein schöner abend